halloween is fun but cavities are no
trick joining us with tips on how to
protect your teeth is dr nicole mackey
from the mackie dental specialty center
welcome hi thank you happy halloween
happy halloween awesome
so i always wanted to ask ask a dentist
and ask you this do you see an uptick in
patients around halloween with all the
candy you know not really because if
people have been doing their regular
brushing and flossing that we recommend
it's it's just another day to celebrate
so
not too much of an arctic yeah so what
are some ways that we can protect our
teeth this halloween season yeah so
the ada the american dental association
and myself recommend brushing twice a
day for two minutes so two and two and
then flossing at least once a day and we
do recommend a fluoride so
when you're at the store and you want to
buy some products the american dental
association has a really cool
seal on all the products that we
recommend and they can be any brand i
mean even a store-bought brand has the
label right on there so you know it's
going to be fine i have never known this
because okay so look at that little ada
thing right there
where we're going 80 yeah you look for
that so you know it's approved that's
great right so
that will help and then you want to
brush your teeth for two minutes on all
the surfaces the sides the top and the
underneath part and you want to hold
your toothbrush at a 45 degree angle and
not brush too hard because brushing too
hard can actually cause gum recession oh
no frankenstein i've been doing that
wrong i'm a hard brusher you have to be
very gentle like you're almost like
you're brushing crystal exactly and if
you have an electric toothbrush just let
it do its thing don't even don't move it
back no additional pressure
i've been doing everything wrong my
entire life okay now when it comes to
halloween are there certain candies that
the kids should eat and stay away from
yeah so i mean if you've been keeping up
with your hygiene let's celebrate let's
indulge a little bit but there are some
better ones and there are some not so
good ones okay this would be good break
it down what are some start with the
good ones yeah okay the good ones
chocolate chocolate is great because it
washes off teeth easily
and a lot of people like chocolate so
it's very popular so chocolate's a good
one you can't go wrong the kids are
gonna throw something at your house if
you give a hershey's bar exactly and
then there's dark chocolate which has
even less sugar and then if you put it
with peanut butter and almond you have a
little bit of protein which helps too
with nutritional value yeah okay now so
not so good not so good i'm looking at
this these are all the candies that i
like but they're also hurting my teeth
right now yeah these ones are a little
bit more
not so teeth friendly um the bacteria in
our mouth love sugar and that's how
cavities form a low acid happens so
sticky guys
ones that are going to be in your mouth
for a really long time you're just
coating it with sugar yes and also these
are hard if you bite into it you could
break a tooth or if you're an adult or
someone who has veneers or crowns and
stuff you got to be careful like like a
starbucks or dots or something too
acidic and sticky so the material stays
in the teeth a little bit too long and
then there's even more acid which helps
break down the tooth even faster you've
been fantastic i do have to wrap it up
one quick question should with kids with
their candy should they eat it all like
within the first couple days or space it
out no it's it's actually good to eat
your candy in one sitting and then brush
your teeth you don't want to keep eating
throughout the day throughout the day
throughout the day because that will
just bathe your teeth and sugar such
great stuff thank you so much doctor we
appreciate it